I think it's been one of the most
wonderful rides that any actor could
ever have to be around Terry who has a
an incredible mind it's exploding all
the time with images and thoughts and
ideas and sometimes when you're actually
on set and in the middle of a scene
he will come walking up and say don't
say that don't say that at all say this
and then he'll tell you a sentence to
say and if it comes out all right he'll
say okay okay we're gonna use that his
mind is so fertile he has such a
wonderful imagination it was impossible
to get into his head he didn't finish
sentences to go with the flow and the
first 10 days as you remember we start
to go over-budget over everything and
Derek came to me and said I really care
for you but you've gotta let me stop the
movie for 12 days to reorganize the
whole thing I said what you said the
famous word trust me and I had no choice
and actually it came out great he is in
love with making movies
Terry had seen a TV show that I was
doing it was very very popular in
England it was called soap and I played
a kind of wacky character in that and
that's what he was looking for or
somebody that could just go with
whatever he wanted and to change on the
spur of the moment and to be in to be in
love with what they were doing because
he's so in love with the the work that
he does
I played mrs. ogre and Time Bandits he
called and said did he have another film
called Brazil
I said wonderful we're going to Brazil
and he said what and I said we're going
to Brazil and he said no what gave you
that idea I said well the name of the
movie is Brazil and he said oh yeah that
has nothing to do with it it's
impossible to describe the movie but I
asked him what really do you want to do
and I said there is something called
Brazil I said
Brazil one documentary semana Brazil is
a song but you know which describes
escape than beautiful things and it's
interesting tell me a little more and
you start to tell me images of eyeballs
of women flying with blond hair and
short but I was watching him and I
realized I'm not actually following the
story but I'm following the passion a
man was totally dedicated to something
that I knew what it's always about it
was about actually the ability to escape
through your mind even if you're tied to
a chair and tortured and there were love
little other things in it but I know
that the next morning I woke up and I
called my lawyer and said do you know I
just committed to finance this movie
he said what is it call this I think
it's called Brazil and he said with whom
we said derec he said do you know him I
said well I just met him in the bar and
they said can you tell me the story I
actually don't remember I know it's
gonna be great the commitment that he
makes if something goes wrong
everything's okay don't worry don't
worry he keeps some patting people on
the back and saying don't worry don't
worry
and everybody's frowning and thinking
how are we gonna get out of this of all
the work I've done the most chaos I was
ever in was with terry gilliam the most
fun I ever had was with Terry Gilliam
and at the end of the project I was so
proud just so proud of the work that was
done